the species can survive
with one man
[Music]
the species cannot survive with a
shortage of women
Food For Thought gentlemen
is this flirting I think this is
flirting for feminists
he says you know the species can survive
with one man how's that sound to you
buddy you know you you get all of us
it's like oh thanks well I'm good hard
pass you know I'm married so it's okay
thank you though but we can't survive
with a shortage of women well of course
you can survive with a shortage of women
couldn't survive with no women but the
species could survive with a shortage a
shortages of women sometimes in
different places I don't think I'd want
to be that one man